in five four three countdown every
[ __ ] time two one welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast today it's just us man that's
right baby
that's right [ __ ] everybody else it's
actually been a while for us because we
recorded like a [ __ ] ton like a month
ago yeah it's good because now we could
do our own [ __ ] and then still connect
with you guys on a weekly basis I know
and it's like they get us every single
week but we don't have to do this every
single week
yeah you know I actually have a question
for you cuz I know you don't watch
sports yeah
but um so a little bit ago so you know
who Jeremy Lin is right yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I actually met Jeremy Lin way
back when when I first started doing
YouTube oh no [ __ ] yeah and then we did
a show together out in Berkeley and this
is before linsanity and everything else
and I used to watch him when he played
college ball but damn really nice dude
really cool guy I actually have a
picture with him I'm might even upload
it who knows man you know me I know I
know important people but uh yeah so
Jeremy Lin recently he there was like a
video of him where he was I don't know
what conference it was at but he was
talking on a podium and a mic and then
he started crying and he was saying oh I
heard about this I didn't see that clip
but it was him like talking about the
struggles of like drafting and all this
stuff like we're the behind the scenes
of basketball yeah and he was like blah
he goes he says he feels like the NBA
forgot about me or something right yeah
so my my thing is like so that kind of
became up as a topic where it was like
people were kind of like one like they
felt bad for him
yeah or two they were like what the [ __ ]
are you crying about like you're
ungrateful kind of thing kind of and
like you know when I started thinking
about it to like number one he's he's
the first NBA player to ever get a
[ __ ] championship ring right number
one right off the bat that asian with a
championship ring yeah oh [ __ ] amazing
yeah I mean didn't get one you know
saying ham and so when I when I look at
that and I saw that video I can I can
kind of understand why people were kind
of like [ __ ] man up like don't be a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like I
understand that concept right because if
you look at it from that perspective
I see somebody so what people are seeing
on the other side they go it's not about
the money like how would you feel if you
were doing something and then you
couldn't do what you loved anymore this
is how I see it
there are amazing basketball players
better than Jeremy Lin Jeremy Lin noses
too way better than him as a player yeah
right that never got a championship ring
yeah that hasn't even had the remote
amount of success that Jeremy Lin has
had Yeah right so during his Linsanity
phase he did this he [ __ ] smashed it
at the Knicks yeah and then on top of
that he got signed to like me don't
quote me on this but he had like a three
year forty million dollar contract with
somebody uh-oh so but if we take the
money equation out of it he's had a very
long basketball career right yeah and
now he's a free agent he might get
picked up by somebody else which he
probably will very long career very
successful career and I'll top of that
he has an amazing fan base there are
people in the NBA who were who was
arguably better than him yeah that
doesn't have the amount of success that
he has so that's one side of the
argument that was kind of like the
ungrateful part yeah it's like just like
man you have all these things going for
you but you're still upset about what
exactly so it's like he's looking at the
glass half-empty
yeah and my thing in my opinion about
this is this might be not be too popular
because I think he's a really dope
person yeah my thing is for me don't be
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] because I am
because how I see it is this like I kind
of agree with that side you're looking
at your glass half-empty yeah and even
if you tell me like well you don't know
what it's like to be doing something
your whole life and then suddenly people
don't want you anymore that's not how I
see it I see it as half-full
you have had a very long and successful
career and now you're a free agent which
you probably can't get picked up
somewhere else or still played for the
love of the game yes if you're not in
the NBA right yeah and then on top of
that financially you're stable let's
take the money part out right you have
you are the first Asian American to have
a championship [ __ ] ring you have a
huge [ __ ] fan base yeah and on top of
that bro you had a moment where you
shine like people forever in the history
of them you remember linsanity yeah that
was crazy it was other people who did it
no basketball new who yeah right and
you're talking about people like for
example like team act Tracy McGrady
didn't even get a [ __ ] ring he
are you believe one of the best people
to have ever played basketball ever
Charles Barkley didn't get a [ __ ]
ring
there's a lot of people who didn't get a
ring and you got that so I am so so for
me when I see him up there and he's
crying number one it just reinforces
this whole concept of Asian dudes being
kind of like weak and flimsy what was he
saying exactly cuz I didn't see the
whole thing I think he's always been on
this rhetoric of like people don't know
how hard it is to be me like an
asian-american NBA basketball player and
I get it I'm not in your shoes bro but
and I'm not saying it's wrong for you to
have emotions and feel that way
yeah but for me how I see it is you
don't look at your glass half-empty I
guess that's my advice would be to him
yeah is you have had a very very
successful career and it's still going
now it's not gonna end you know and I
think for him he's very emotional
because he feels like well there's like
the NBA doesn't really want me anymore
but at the same time and people might
disagree with me on this if you were
that [ __ ] amazing at basketball the
NBA would want you I mean yeah it's I
think it's a it's not understanding
where to vent yeah so like if you're
doing it on a public platform like this
right is you're gonna get all kinds of
different opinions coming at you for
sure this is something that you say to
to another Asian professional basketball
player that can understand your struggle
together yeah or doesn't even have to be
Asian but another athlete in the same
boat as you like if we started out
really complaining about all of our
YouTube woes and all these things we
will get the same kind of ridicule
people will be like man what are you
talking about bro you drive this you
[ __ ] live like I saw you come up you
[ __ ] do this well like you got this
going for you I ain't got [ __ ] man
I found a workout fast food I ain't got
no [ __ ] dream like and it's like I
get it dude I sound like a dick like
special especially if there's some dude
in India watching my [ __ ] right now and
and Daffy was like lucky enough to have
water to drink right and he's like what
are you talking about Joe yeah yeah yeah
and it's it's it's if but if I could sit
here and I vent it to you we have this
like community right like you could do
this [ __ ] all day and we could talk [ __ ]
about
things that we don't get or whatever but
at the end of the day like I know that
if I do that out in public people are
going to ridicule me and I have to
understand that yeah same would staying
with Jeremy like he has to understand
that if you do this not everyone's gonna
be on your side and be like yo man
you're so brave for like talking about
depression and all that you're gonna get
that but you're also gonna get a lot of
people that are like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about bro
I'll [ __ ] work at McDonald's and I
have no [ __ ] chance of being an MBA
even and even though I wanted to yeah
you know like this perspective it is
perspective you're right the the the
platform that he used it on for him to
like like I said I like the fact that
he's human and I like the fact that he
could emot-- and he could show those
emotions because you know sometimes when
people are put on a pedestal like yeah
they don't want you to feel or be a
human being which is cool but the I
think the misstep on his part was for
him to expect people to uh maybe
understand what he's going through it
yeah but sense because we don't [ __ ]
know but well also maybe he was trying
to let people know that the grass isn't
always greener and we know this like a
celebrity being rich being all these
things like people always have this idea
of I must be so awesome to dictate your
own hours and do this and do that and
then we even have those kind of guys
like within or proximity in like they're
just living normal but they have a
little bit of shade and salt and
jealousy and and and you can sense that
like when you're hanging out you know
and then they say some [ __ ] like Oh must
be nice you're always what are you
complaining about you know it's like
shut the [ __ ] up like it's not always
gonna be greater but this is I think
human nature to think oh if I only had
money oh if I only had Fame if I only
had all these things but we know for a
fact like from Khalif that but can being
an athlete sucks yes it's a lot of hard
work it is crazy hard work yeah 60 hours
of training a week yeah no fun no play
just eating and sleeping and training
and what you love becomes torture yeah
and yeah the hard part about that I was
kind of reading online too but I guess I
couldn't understand cuz I'm try get both
sides yeah is that when he when he when
you phrase the word especially in a
competitive sport yeah where
the were you're the reason why you're
hired and put on to a team or people
covet you is based on skill yeah right
so for him to say and this is what I'm
saying I'm reflecting enough what other
people are saying they're saying that
for him to put out the line the NBA for
god about me it's also him not
acknowledging hey at the same time maybe
your skills aren't as good as you think
it is yeah so he it's almost like he's
playing the race card you think that's
what I think that's what people are kind
of feeling it's like well how many times
can you do this sob story right because
if you were a Kobe level athlete right
yeah if you were a Kobe level athlete
would you be having this conversation
right now on this podium and so it's
true I guess to some people it sounds
like he's not taking that full
responsibility of saying like okay well
maybe my skills aren't as good as I
thought it was and I need to up my game
so I need to show people what I'm what
I'm about because that's what linsanity
was yeah up his game and he show people
yo I'm [ __ ] worth my weight in gold
yeah
don't make me a benchwarmer exactly and
so you know I don't know the politics
behind what happens in the NBA but when
you put a public statement out like that
people can't interpret it that way they
can't say like yo bro if you're dope is
you think that you are do you would you
be a free agent right now that's true
robably not you're right hello everybody
this podcast is brought to you by Mack
Weldon if you don't know what Mack
Weldon is well let me tell you Mack
Weldon believes in smart design premium
fabrics and simple shopping now if we're
talking about simple shopping I'm
talking about Mack wealth and my friends
because their shopping experience is
absolutely amazing specifically because
the website is super clean and very easy
to use Mack Weldon will be the most
comfortable underwear socks shirts
undershirts hoodies and sweatpants and
more that you will ever wear they have a
line of silver underwear shirts that are
naturally antimicrobial for you people
out there that tend to sweat a lot and
smell a lot antimicrobial my friends
keeps you nice and fresh they want you
to be comfortable so if you don't like
your first pair you can keep it and they
will still refund you no questions asked
not only does Mack Weldon's underwear
socks and shirts look good they perform
well too for me I received my to sweat
pants and my swimming trunks
and also I got one of their Mac Weldon
like simple fabric wallets I got to tell
you Mac Walden's quality is really good
on top of the quality it's just a lot of
the stuff is really stylish
like the swim trunks that I got it's by
far my best pair of swim trunks I've
ever had
Claudia wise fit wise and style wise and
I'm about to go to Hawaii in a couple of
weeks and I'll tell you this right now
my friends uh May Jing so check it out
for 20% off your first order visit Mac
Weldon dot-com and enter promo code GB
at the checkout to get your discount
once again for 20% off your first order
visit Mac Weldon dot-com and enter the
promo code GB at the checkout give Mac
well gonna try is actually stuff that I
really do wear very simple very clean
and if you like fashion basics or you
just like good quality products give
back well gonna try I love it I mean I
say this to the same thing about like
Asians and action movies or whatever
it's like it's not that you don't get
picked because you're Asian it's because
you're not Bruce Lee but if you were as
innovative pioneering you were just the
[ __ ] amazing God at what you did and
you change the world I mean there's I
mean it's difficult to be that but that
if you become that people cannot deny
your talent everyone's going for you
Kobe Michael Jordan [ __ ] Mike Tyson
like everybody in their field if you are
that guy everybody wants you yeah every
[ __ ] body yeah and like you're right
dude as an entertainer and an athlete we
this is a cutthroat competitive place
for sure like we all leave nine to five
jobs to perform in this realm and it's
not the same as like oh pick me please I
want to I want it I want it to be fair
to like it's it's it's a [ __ ] crying
dude yeah it's a different world
yeah so I feel like even though it sucks
for him because I get those issues that
he's going through we chose this life
and it's different from working like
that regular job yeah that's the
[ __ ] that we signed up for dude cuz for
me because I've you know I used to be a
big fan of basket by still wash ball
today um I just I haven't seen that
version of somebody go up there in their
youth where they had just won a
championship bring and go the NBA forgot
to me and they bawled and they were
crying right now so I haven't seen that
in some other and be a player so it's a
little off-putting for me yeah and I
think what happens is that when when him
and when he's in that position it kind
of comes off as oh it's because I'm
Asian and I hear and I and I really
really dislike that you know yeah you
know what though I also feel for the
guys that don't want the responsibility
of being the only Asian guy you know
like we're very maverick in a way where
we're like [ __ ] you like yeah
[ __ ] I'm Asian and I represent
and I don't give a [ __ ] right some
people don't want that attention and
they don't want that extra pressure of
like [ __ ] dude like I don't want this
whole token asian guy thing like I just
want to play basketball yeah yeah um so
I get it where he might feel the added
pressure of other Asians like going like
hey man why don't you [ __ ] do this
and that and then they're carrying the
weight of the race we're but I can white
people don't really have to do that so
in sports
yeah probably an NBA I think for him
though the positive thing haha how I saw
it anyways was whether I mean let's just
keep it real if you guys watch ball I
mean Jeremy Lin's not the best ball
player out there you know I mean like he
facilitates the ball here and there and
people found out his game and they
started shutting him down
yeah dual insanity they saw what his
game was yeah and so with him he
actually in my opinion maybe it's cuz
I'm always trying to see hit the glass
half-full yeah is that no matter what he
did people [ __ ] with him heavy because
it was nice to see one of our faces on
the court in it so he had a lot of
support he had a lot of spirit dude you
how many Asian people do you hear out
there say anything bad about him whether
he's an amazing ball player or not it's
just the fact that no that's like we got
one on our team you know like hell yeah
so it's it's mad love
I barely watch basketball and I'm even
like proud of that
exactly cuz but then I guess my point is
that he might not even want that
attention and pressure maybe because if
he if it you know like the feeling of
like if he [ __ ] up he's letting all of
us down
you know like we're like different we're
like will [ __ ] you like well yeah and
then you know what let me put my [ __ ]
I'm gonna be forward about this because
I rather represent Asians before this
[ __ ] over here that that that that's a
pretender yeah
and we know those [ __ ] it's like [ __ ]
you I don't want you to be like the face
of Asians 1 or 2 you know with him like
in his position 2 I always wonder when
somebody is at that type of level of
success I wonder who's in his corner and
who's talking to him if they're feeding
into his self-pity and like self-hate
and selfs at like this type of sadness
because if you had somebody in this
corner maybe telling it was like bro
maybe yo you should really need to put a
positive spin on this because right now
you're wallowing in the sadness that
really you it's it's within your control
yeah right like you're like you're you
are a good basketball player yeah you
can do this or and I think for me too
another another side of it because you
know he talks highly about his faith as
a Christian so I was like why don't you
lean into your faith you know if you
true if because I grew up at a church
yeah cuz this is a clear sign of no
social support yeah that's what it
sounds rying on stage that and breaking
down like and you know like there's no I
think that's like breaking the level of
professionalism yeah right and although
men you know we're trained to like not
show emotions and people are saying what
he did was brave and all that stuff I
think also you wanna pay attention to
the group vibes and where to properly do
that like if this was an Oprah
one-on-one thing or dr. Phil and he's
crying his eyes out and being like that
I think that's an appropriate place to
express that but at a press conference
or something else I'm like I don't know
if that's a place to do that yeah right
so it's not wrong to show your emotion I
think there's always a time and place to
express certain things and and you could
you if you do so beware of the
consequence and the ridicule of what is
about to happen yeah that's that's
that's the thing too I just like you
know you maybe you are
right about the whole thing of life
there's a lot of pressure for him to
uphold a certain image because there's
this pressure of like you on that asian
dude that's yes yeah a player and if he
fails he's maybe you know you know you
know what it is I think it's it if I can
be in his shoes it's like I haven't
failed yet but I'm waiting for the day
that I do and everyone's gonna hate me
so he might that might be in his head
where it's like well they don't hate me
yet but when I do [ __ ] up they're all
gonna turn and I'm gonna fail all of
Asia and it's up to me like I gotta set
the best example I gotta kill it because
if I don't do this then they're not
gonna give Asians another chance in the
next ten years
yeah there's a lot of that pressure
imagine pressure obviously like but it's
like a Jon Snow situation like he didn't
want to be king but people are like
you're so good for that like do it you
know and I also feel like I'm a [ __ ]
caveman too because i let's say [ __ ]
if I ever had that type of out and
somebody get I had forty million dollars
in the bank I'm like you could trade me
drop me you could [ __ ] me in the ass I
don't care I have forty million dollars
yes but that's also why I'm not an
elite-level app right I'm not in that
type of position because that that
argument right there is I say doesn't
really make too much sense because
they're not really kind of taking to the
the part of him as a human being right
because some people just they don't
really care about the money as much for
sure some people they care so much about
the athleticism winning part and then
the image part and then how people look
at them like is what I had to stomach
because I used to look down at people
that were more into vanity or more into
the likes or more but it's just we all
value different [ __ ] yeah so some people
they value so much what other people
think of them and there's their place in
society and that's just their world man
and I used to be like you're a [ __ ]
loser but now I'm like nah dude like
there's just too many people with
different value systems
I think being like Korean or Japanese
that's the hard part or we call
everybody [ __ ] losers it was beat
into us right
it's like we we weren't allowed to think
petty or else you get [ __ ] up yeah and
you know on top of that man it's just
[ __ ] man like
I feel like every time a Korean person
would make a move within this so-called
made-up community we like my parents
thank god they're not like this anymore
but they were when my dad was a pastor
right and a bigger Church but he had to
think about everything that they did if
I do this is this person gonna say
something about whoa
is this person gonna say something about
what I yeah because that was the most
annoying part for me because I could
give a [ __ ] means right there's so much
social pressure allah yeah and so like I
know my for example my mom and dad
usually get in a lot of fights because
my mom was a trash bag like she [ __ ]
like I love her to death but that
woman's a country-ass bumpkin dude and
mind you like when you're a pastor so
like it's ruining the image of your dad
yeah so my dad's a book sigh and then
they called the wife of the pastor's
homonym so my mom says how many mean
they expect this homonym to behave like
us how many like very like my Bieber
yeah and I said oh you know a
conservative Christian wife exactly but
my mom be cursing up a storm
she's like she be say some wild [ __ ]
that my dad side do you have any idea
how that makes me look my mom like she
goes out pissed right now she's doing
rice cooker that my dad and [ __ ] and so
like that's that's the thing too it
would it social pressure also seeps into
your daily lives my mom's like you know
why can't I just be me just because you
made this life choice ya know I gotta
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] yeah I do to my mom
on every Sunday every Sunday she would
either make the hunger Occulus of Korean
school yeah she would make the
sandwiches and all this other [ __ ] on
Sunday after working 80 hours Monday
through Saturday and then I would make
the sandwiches to for the Korean class
yeah there every right to custody yeah
and then she would do [ __ ] a lunch
for the church I thought about a church
of my [ __ ] like 300 people because
she's like putting in work but not being
like appreciated yeah it is it's like
she cusses too much it's like I've done
all of and I understand it's like I've
done all this stuff and then I slip up
with this and it's like do you see how
it's like hold on [ __ ] yeah I think I
just made food for 300 people I will
[ __ ] kill I started appreciating my
mom more when I started cooking for Pete
it was hard for me to cook for seven
people yeah I was like how the [ __ ] do
you cook for seven people
that's pretty gangster dude yeah and
then she would do that [ __ ] every Sunday
so money where we hundred people it was
correct and dude have you been to like a
did you guys have this at like at your
Japanese Church were during like
Thanksgiving or any type of like
festivity the food was boy better well
we would have potlucks
yeah like toddlers holux was dope every
every Church yeah people bring potlucks
and then once in a while like they'll
get together and cook some [ __ ] up and
stuff yeah my mom would do like the Chi
like so for Christmas Thanksgiving
Easter and these bigger celebrations on
the set the food was [ __ ] good it was
like I'd be like Chapter look at the
Korean glass noodles or [ __ ] it would
and it would be like ten side dishes
rice yeah they have like they have like
the Korean mochi thunk and also there's
stuff here you know I Thanksgiving
Easter any type of celebrated let
holiday dog the food was [ __ ] amazing
man man that social pressure [ __ ] is no
joke though you're giving me flashbacks
like I remember like hating my parents
because they cared so [ __ ] much about
what the village thought yeah they cared
so [ __ ] much and I guess now that I'm
older I understand like that's how you
create a good society is like you check
each other yeah this that social
pressure is makes making sure like in a
good way right it makes you not do shady
[ __ ] makes you work think twice about
like [ __ ] people over because the
rumors or you know it keeps people kind
of in control and I think that's a one
of the good things about Asian culture
is like we with that fear people are
pressed to work harder they're pressed
to do better they're pressed to like not
be homeless and [ __ ] like that
well like I realize that when you have
too much freedom in society there's no
accountability like you're not pressing
that full to get up out of this [ __ ] and
then do something yeah but if you have
all these Asian aunties telling you you
know you need to do this you need to do
that all down to your health like
they're [ __ ] with your weight they're
[ __ ] with your school they're [ __ ]
everything you know what I used to hate
I used to hate like going to church and
then [ __ ] up and then getting my ass
beat by a stranger
I think getting my ass beat by my dad
after could you embarrass the family
right yeah [ __ ] are you dude and this
guy would kick my ass and but he has
full rein to do it and then my dad would
be like why did you make him kick your
ass I'll just get my ass beat by
everybody in the church [ __ ] [ __ ]
suck man but I mean okay there's
probably a way better [ __ ] way to do
it but I can see why all right now I
think being older I can see the results
it's like it's like it works but now
everyone's traumatized and [ __ ] hurt
everybody gets traumatized know what the
funny thing is people are like why are
agent so like smart and all that's like
man Asians are actually dumb as [ __ ]
they're just beat into [ __ ] studying
like a [ __ ] it's repetition dude
yes it's repetition I feel it's weird
because I think when I think about and
being in the future and having a kid
myself like what I'm gonna have my kid I
always think like [ __ ] I hope I don't
have the same bad habits that my dad did
you know I mean but I feel like I am
it's just gonna be a watered down
version because he's just a watered down
version of his father
yeah that's me I mean I mean I'm
verbally abuse I don't even know what
that meant
but I'm like oh I'm not I'm not violent
and I'm not abusive because I'm not
beating anybody really you see who my
dad was you know I'm gonna say so I
didn't know that I was violent I didn't
know there was ways of being violent
without physical harm yeah I I realized
that a lot of people will consider
what's the word aggressive speaking and
smashing things as violence yeah I
didn't know that that was a part of that
category I don't even know how petty I
was until recently I was like because
what I you know I said buddy would you
catch it - right yeah Oh Patti did you
know why it's because I find I didn't
realize how petty it was until actually
I met Steve and then Steve was like oh
we're kind of similar I was like no
you're a petty bro you troll a lot I was
like on a second I do that too all the
time I just didn't realize I was doing
it
right because I do things out of for
entertainment yeah so like you know
every time we do like a JK news I always
throw shade yeah it's all because it
just makes me laugh yeah right but that
it becomes it becomes manifest into
something where people are like do you
[ __ ] despise these guys it's like
just we be guys like I guess I'm just I
just feed into it yeah it's just funny
it's just funny to me
yeah right and so it's like oh it's like
why do you do it that's like I don't
know I think I do it because I'm pretty
sure it bothers death it makes me laugh
cuz they're bad guys or they're not
terribly with bigs or anything and you
know like I read these comments and yeah
like so what's the beat there's no beef
it's just it's just funny when it's it's
kind of like you're a big brother and
then you see a little brother like
[ __ ] and you know it bothers them
when something happens and you just
[ __ ] egged on even doing it like you
hide the controller and it drives them
nuts and you like watching them yeah
it's so [ __ ] funny it's like that
troll type of personality you're a troll
I mean we all are in some way right cuz
we were into comedy yeah yeah but it's
like at what extent yeah I wonder - do
you do you I know because you don't
really go to church anymore right no and
I I go to church I try to so maybe like
twice a month once a month at least yeah
I always wonder because for me I kind of
I like the right Church right and I feel
like a lot of the moral things that I
gathered as an adult now I actually
learned from church so I wonder if I'm
going to put if I I'll put my kids in
church just to get those that moral
foundation that maybe I might not do so
well you know because there's like free
daycare too and they did a lot of like
group activities that I thought that's
what I missed man yeah I missed my
friends I missed the pot Luck's I miss
hanging out I missed the mission trips I
think those things yeah I definitely
want or something similar to it if it's
not within a church yeah I'd like the
mission trips a lot because the one
thing that it did teach me a lot growing
up was to know my place in this world
it's like you can complain and then it
also routes back to that but the Jeremy
Lin thing that the thing that runs me
the wrong way a little bit yes he is
hyper Christian right and if he did do
mission trips and
there's a lack of appreciation in that
kind of talking yeah yeah so it always
that's what always roots and grounds me
back and when you go to a thorough
[ __ ] country you'd come back you're
just like oh my god I'm a little [ __ ] I
complain too much dude there was his
moment in in in Mexico when we were
doing this mission trip there's this
little kid that came up to me and I felt
like a little [ __ ]
so this kid and there's like a bunch of
stray dog that's in like Tijuana and so
that some of them are a little vicious
his kid was just walking around the
streets barefoot chillin and then one of
the people that were translating for me
they saw that I was like scared and
freaked out yeah and he was like
laughing and I'll say Oh what did the
kids say he goes well why is he so he
goes he goes you know he goes well we
all love and believe in God he goes why
is he so scared it wouldn't when God's
always by him and I said this
[ __ ] trying to make me cry but
he said he didn't you know Spanish I'd
understand but they translated for me I
was like damn do this will put me in my
[ __ ] place man but seeing how other
people live really makes me go back to
like yo don't really complain so much
yeah yeah we're all allowed to complain
and we make jokes about all Thai
complain all the [ __ ] time but at the
end of the day it's like that just just
understanding where you are in this
world which is why I [ __ ] love
traveling a lot yeah helps me put things
in perspective a lot it's like yo bro
don't see the same things though like I
would travel with some people that have
never gone to church and those things
and they just like it goes over their
head oh really because it's like they're
aliens mmm you know it's it's it's not
like a human being I think and and I
think people just kind of
compartmentalize that like thinking I I
look at people now or even yesterday I
walked around the neighborhood and I
went to this Ralph's around the corner
and there was his lady she was homeless
and she had some kind of ailment where
her her feet kind of looked like stone
do you know have you seen that before
where it kind of engorges really big
it's like elephant yeah yeah and it's
like like scales or yeah she's sitting
there with no shoes and dogs like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up the whole night really
I cuz I I but I started thinking about
was I looked at her nose like there was
a point in her life where she was a kid
when she was a kid she didn't have these
problems she was like probably carefree
and smart and bright and somehow she got
she died in a crack or something like
something happened she got the crack
dance something happened along the way
where she ended up like this and I want
to know what those pieces are and why it
happened that way I'm like the opposite
dude you know what I think I go
Mussolini Hitler Mao all these [ __ ]
were once little children which one of
these [ __ ] kids are gonna be a
[ __ ] I deconstruct the other way like
I guess that I'm like damn did you used
to be a baby what the [ __ ] happened in
your life man like what the [ __ ] led up
to this point because as we get older to
that the biggest thing that's been
hitting me now especially because we're
finding out a lot about ourselves as all
these habits that we have were developed
at a young age yeah just don't [ __ ]
know oh man it is I mean I think it's a
I think that's the base of
psychoanalysis I think it's cycle and
now yeah there's a there's a there's a
psychology method where they believe
that we go throughout life just trying
to figure out all the [ __ ] that
happened to us as kids mm-hmm and we
just got to rework all that trauma yeah
and and you spend the most of your adult
years just trying to identify and rework
that and some people they live blind for
the rest of our lives you know yeah I I
definitely I don't know what it is maybe
as I as we get older we get a little
more empathetic like I definitely do do
man I'm [ __ ] everything makes me tear
up now dude I'm soft this [ __ ] bro I'm
like oh [ __ ] or testosterone is kind of
like chilling out too and you know what
I think it is is that we're starting to
see like Oh
kids I was a kid I could make kids cuz
guys are stupid like we think ass stick
my dick in the ass doh yeah you don't
think that's that's a titty and a baby
drinks out of that yeah you think that's
a titty I want it in my face yeah yeah
and or like it's it we're very
short-sighted like we know okay I know
like having sex can pop a baby out but
like do you really know
do you really like guys don't think like
that but [ __ ] condoms feel terrible I
think I'm super short-sighted I think
we're very very we're like goldfish
right if it's not in front of our face
we don't make those connections until
you become old wise man dude I saw a
video on Twitter this kid jacking off on
a plane bcs yeah yeah yeah whatever we
had the blanket like this and you're
doing like that this fool was beating
his dick like it owed it money dude this
[ __ ] was jacking off so [ __ ]
hard dude did you see the the trail of
videos under that of other people
jacking off on the airplane oh she's a
bald guy that was beating off in his
like hey hey you bought by the [ __ ]
stop that [ __ ] right now stop that
little old guy yeah well he was like
maybe in his 40s or something see that's
so weird because he was just like bald
like like a nerd and yeah I could
imagine a teenager doing that because
ladies if you don't understand when when
there's a teenage boy there's urges that
they had they had the hardest time
controlling man so like for me when I
see that type of [ __ ] and people like
don't you miss it when you were young no
I do not
I said I'm surprised that there's not
more teen pregnancies oh sure dude this
kid was beating his dick so [ __ ] hard
I've never seen somebody masturbate like
that it was almost like the first time
he ever masturbated ever like he just
got his dick he left the window slightly
open so the [ __ ] light was shining
through hit the blanket so all you see
is a silhouette of this kid just mashing
his dick like a bunch of [ __ ] English
peas turning the [ __ ] body that [ __ ]
was crazy he's so funny because he
thought that just we're just having that
blanket over him but still beating off
would hide everything dude do you
remember the first time you masturbated
nah I don't remember the first time you
was funny I couldn't remember for the
longest time and I remember on a JK news
Bart was talking about the first time he
messed but he yeah I remember the first
time and then after a while I don't know
why but you know when you have
conversation it like ignites some type
of synapses right yeah so I remembered
the
first time I masturbated [ __ ] after Bart
kept talking about I was like so I
remember the first time I'm asked MIT
and the first time I came it hurt yeah I
remember I was dry heaving yeah I
remember they're like not the first time
I came but I remember coming back in
those days I remember it hurt Oh what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] [ __ ] I never
feel weird after yeah yeah it's not
because you get a boner again yeah then
like I remember like wet dreams and all
this other [ __ ] oh yeah I should [ __ ]
sucked as a kid dude it did especially
if you just crazy [ __ ] horny man like
I feel like if kids didn't have porn
today or like what the [ __ ] did they do
back in the day it everything that's why
kids were getting married and [ __ ]
having babies at 14 15 years old I think
all those [ __ ] high-lows [ __ ]
hardcore Christian kids get married
early so they kept up they just trying
to but without God judging oh yeah these
[ __ ] did like I don't you ain't
full of no body dude you were literally
getting married so you could [ __ ] the
eyes of the Lord dude like this dude's
out they'll get married like 17 and all
of a sudden that's like [ __ ] all the
time and I'm like look at you you just
wanted to [ __ ] and now your marriage is
all that stuff and [ __ ] because they
just wanted to [ __ ] do it real quick
they wanted to [ __ ] without the guilt
yeah I mean that's why I'm like I think
y'all should just get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] out but do it do it when you're
older like jackoff as much as you can
because be careful with that [ __ ] man
the month the moment my kid starts
jacking off and I see crust on their
underwear they're doing their own
laundry
[ __ ] picking up their boxers and it
looks like a [ __ ] like a plastic
plate I'm like [ __ ] you do your own
laundry now man [ __ ] disgusting
creature hey bat [ __ ] jagged always like
a sport though like I think it's funny
like how much you do that [ __ ] in your
teens and much time you spend like if I
spent all that time actually doing my
homework and becoming smarter I would
have been so much more successful but
it's hard to think that you don't
masturbate bro it is dude I'm just
trying to read a [ __ ] sentence and I
go three sentences and I'm like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] up jacking off
[Laughter]
it's like in reading the Bible verse two
in the beginning fuckness give me my big
yeah I'm like trying to type a [ __ ]
essay and I'm on the I'm on the computer
and in the next minute my pants are mom
around my ankles I'm [ __ ] jacking off
like a [ __ ] and in the next
minute I'm taking a [ __ ] nap cuz I
just jacked off were you there when they
when Nick told that story about him
jacking off when he was a kid it he's
got caught he got caught with it
when his dad was height stop jacking up
cuz his foot was so loud with it inside
the shower they stop jacking off the how
loud were you jacking off Nick with all
the hair all yours cuz I kick cut that
[ __ ] out dude I can hear it it's [ __ ]
disgusting oh my god so when we were
cavemen right I think like see this is a
good thing that girls are like more
cautious when they're younger yeah cuz
if girls were just as crazy horny as
boys oh my god we would be having kids
all over at like 13 14
oh for sure all over for sure died I
can't I'm pretty sure that if I had sex
like during high school cuz I had the
first time I had sex was I was when I
was 18 and it was after I graduated so
I'm pretty sure I would have had a kid
because of how reckless I was even after
18 I'm surprised I didn't have a kid
then and every girl you get with you
think they're the love of your life and
you're gonna marry them forever so you
just you just stupid
my very first girlfriend I thought that
she was it I was like you are the last
person that I will ever have sex with
and I'm gonna have kids with you we're
gonna have that he's house feelings
these [ __ ] feelings man it's weird
too because sometimes like randomly out
of nowhere like I'll have a dream and
she pops in my dream like my very and I
don't even remember what she I haven't
seen her since I was like 20 years old
hell and it's so random
like she your girlfriend at the time or
you guys just kind of in the dream no no
like back then was your girlfriend or
you guys just kind of hooked
oh no she was my girlfriend the first
person I ever had sex was was my
actual girlfriend so it's got a weird
like when she pops up in in a dream but
it's not even like we're together if
she's there and I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here but team the teen sex
though wasn't even as good cuz it's like
you don't know what the vibe I'm pretty
sure she had the woo out of the words
yeah you know life you come so fast I
mean even in my 30s I come faster as a
teen dude it's too it's too [ __ ]
sensitive dude you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're doing like I don't know and
I have no idea what I was doing yeah but
the first time I actually probably I got
checked during sex so after sex it was
just one Filipino girl and she told me I
wasn't good and after that I was like
well you tell me what's good then you
[ __ ] tell me [ __ ] and then you know
she just was very open I mean that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] crazy what the great thing
that came out of that was the
communication that happened happened now
that well I started asking like what
they like what would they prefer what
they don't like just let me know but a
lot of girls wouldn't like the first
girlfriend that I was with because
there's shame right yeah she they don't
want to feel like a hoe and all that so
I think that's why sex gets better when
you're older because you don't feel
comfortable with each other it's you
can't have good sex
yeah and for yeah I said definitely with
when I look back on it like I don't know
what I was doing she didn't know what
she was going and I just thought like
yellow my dicks inside you it probably
feels great because my penis feels just
like [ __ ] and this is dirty little fat
boy that she was having sex with Gracie
little fat [ __ ] when guys get better
with age though I think for sure men and
I think like when I look back on it as
like dude I was I was disgusting man
[ __ ] disgust you she was having sex
with a homeless person that she didn't
know girl they're so nice she got the
worst version I mean let me tell you
lady if you had it now maybe a little
bit better just a little bit to last a
little longer and now I stroked the back
of your head with the back of my head
like romantic hi-yah hi-yah the back of
her head now did you do that teen [ __ ]
you just go and [ __ ] pump away and
then you [ __ ] nut didn't you just
fall asleep I know man it was just so
bad like I
back on it I'm like damn you just really
didn't care man like you just wanted to
get it in as much money yeah it's like
one step above jacking off I'm so
grossed - looks like hygiene wise like
God just as a teen you're just a
disgusting little creature I know I
don't even know how that even worked out
damn girls are troopers man I think we
all didn't know what we wanted or what
what was a good standard yeah I know it
was just like oh is this what sex is I
know I'm like I gotta take a shower my
balls be sweating all day I feel bad for
you when you're licking it I'm like hold
on let me take a shower dude back then
it was like dude I would go three days
without a shower and get my balls licked
and [ __ ] and I'm like I don't care yeah
people just shout out to a Stephanie new
end she's like is that smell like that
yeah of course what are you doing yeah I
mean they're [ __ ] like crazy too you
know and it's like [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] disgusting cave man I think
about sex when we were [ __ ] teenagers
and younger it was pretty gross like we
definitely didn't have a good standard
for what sex was supposed to be yeah
yeah disgusting yeah and I I remember to
just like always feeling unsure about
myself when I was having sex too cuz I
just no self conscious the whole time do
you feel good look at you we would watch
I would watch porn I like trying to
emulate what porn does yeah yeah I'm
like she's not screaming that my dicks
huge I don't know what's going on like
I'm not doing that's right why did you
so quiet she's not morning yeah she's
not moaning his last
maybe I should punch her in her face
like just like in the porno no but the
important was a lot harder to accept
like it wasn't as accessible back
management we're like 17 or 18 so I
don't really had that big of a lexicon
to really derive my information from but
but even the porn back then it was like
the same weird fake [ __ ] yeah I don't
know it's not even that different I hate
doing doggy style back in the day
because that [ __ ] was too much work that
[ __ ] used to get me hella tired I'm like
[ __ ] I hate doggy style this shit's
[ __ ] exhausting man get off my knees
and then I got to grab her and make sure
it's like position her hips right and
it's like and if your legs don't match
too it's like god damn it dude I'm all
I feel too short or I feel too oh yeah
dude yeah and I used to date like really
really short girls so she was [ __ ]
hiring man I'd have to lift them up a
little bit and then start [ __ ] them
that way like you picked up a burrito
big as tempur-pedic oh god dude I was
like are you ready for just flying in
the air god man that's a dirty well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast I know you guys been
noticing that it's like odd like the
videos are only like 45 minutes long
well the reason why is because we want
to bring out more episode for you guys
so if you want to watch more episodes
we've got two coming out every week man
keep it short and sweet yeah but I mean
it's only 15 minutes different than what
we used to do yet do you want one one
hour one or do you want to 45-minute
ones that's the real question I rather
do more yeah man and we could go through
different topics change it up we're not
to talk about one thing for like very
very long time yeah for sure and you
know if you're watching this on on the
youtubes and on the video platforms man
let us know what you think about that
whole Jeremy Lin situation man like
number one I don't want people to get it
twisted I support that guy a hundred
[ __ ] percent and I'm just talking
about my perspective from what I see
right so talk about it in the comments
man let us know what you think do you
think that he should be looking at his
glass half-full do you think that how
would you feel if you were in his
position and how did you feel about him
crying in public and how he feels about
a situation there's so many ways to look
at the same situation yeah man a Jeremy
don't don't cry anymore man what you do
is you take that 40 million dollars that
you made and you dab your [ __ ] little
[ __ ] eyes which they're just [ __ ]
hello hello then you'll be okay guy yeah
I love you Jeremy if I ever see you in
public I'm kissing you on your penis
okay you can see this on you can listen
to us on iTunes podcast we're talking
about Spotify stitcher everything give
us that five-star rating and I will see
you guys in a few days couple weeks or
whatever you or whenever you guys tune
in please